a groundbreaking new law took effect
overnight in New York the child victims
act gives sexual abuse survivors barred
by a statute of limitations a one-year
window to file a civil lawsuit against
their alleged perpetrators and
institutions like the Boy Scouts schools
or the Catholic Church today also
happens to mark one year since the
release of a Pennsylvania grand jury
report on alleged sexual abuse by clergy
in the Catholic Church Niki batiste has
been reporting on this for more than a
year Niki you spoke to a man who filed a
lawsuit against the Catholic Church just
hours ago good morning Anthony that's
right and his story is powerful James
Larney has never spoken publicly about
the sexual abuse he says he suffered as
a child at the hands of a priest in New
York City but today that changes as the
New York child victims Act goes into
effect Larney is coming forward and says
he's ready for his day in court some of
what he has to say may be difficult to
hear my dad always told me the priest is
just one step away from God you must
respect and do whatever he wants you to
do
James Larney says that message from his
devoutly Catholic father intensified the
confusion and fear he experienced at age
13 when he says his then priest
Monsignor Rafael Parnevik began sexually
abusing him in the choir loft at Saint
Anthony of Padua church on Staten Island
very slowly he put his hand behind my
head and I started to cry quietly but he
was not going to stop and he guarded my
head this was the behavior for the next
about 18 months the priest died in 2000
Larney now 66 says by the time II was
ready to come forward it was too late
the statute of limitations for any
criminal or civil recourse had long
passed until now does the New York child
victims Act give you the power back yes
it does I never thought that this moment
would come where I'd be able to legally
seek justice Larney is now suing st.
Anthony of Padua and the Archdiocese of
New York
Jennifer Freeman is his attorney there
are critics who say that some people may
take advantage of the new law to try to
make money what's your response to them
this is about accountability and
responsibility holding those
institutions responsible for what they
allowed or do to children the child
victims act opens a one-year look-back
window in New York during which any
person who was under the age of 18 when
they were sexually abused can file a
civil lawsuit regardless of their age
now victims previously only had until
age 21 to sue an institution at age 23
to sue a perpetrator this isn't just
about money this is about justice and
this is a way America does justice Marcy
Hamilton is the founder of the child
abuse advocacy group child USA she
expects thousands of lawsuits to be
filed against everyone from coaches to
Jeffrey Epstein's
estate we're going to learn about is the
hidden dangers to children hidden child
predators across the state of New York
that nobody knew about and it may not
just be New York according to child USA
nationally a total of 18 states in the
District of Columbia have new statute of
limitation reform laws going into effect
this year four states in d.c are
offering a look-back window what's the
one word you would use to describe the
Catholic Church today
a year later since the grand jury report
corrupt morally corrupt Catholic clergy
abuse survivors Sean Daugherty has
fought for reform in Pennsylvania where
he was sexually abused when he was 10
and where one year ago with a Catholic
Church grand jury
port was released over the past 12
months we've traveled with Daugherty to
Rome for the Vatican sexual abuse summit
and we were there when he confronted
this former priest he says molested him
Daugherty says he won't stop fighting
for change in Pennsylvania where victims
must file civil lawsuits by age 30 a
year ago you said the statute of
limitations is reusing me is that still
the case sure we're going to see people
here in New York file I still don't have
that opportunity this is a photo of my
first communion on the steps of st.
Anthony's but Larney does have the
opportunity and for that he says he's
grateful what do you hope the outcome of
your lawsuit will be I'm hoping that the
Catholic Church wakes up and puts it
into this abuse we reached out to st.
Anthony of Padova about Lonnie's
accusations and the parish directed us
to the Archdiocese of New York
the archdiocese told us there are no
allegations against that priest in his
file and he is not included on any of
the lists of accused priests it is
published it says it hasn't seen lar
knees a lawsuit and cannot comment on it
the archdiocese says it encouraged
anyone with an allegation to immediately
bring it to law enforcement and the law
firm that represents James just one law
firm has more than 500 clients from the
Boy Scout schools filing under this new
law it's so tough to see James Larney as
a little boy smiling his little smiley
face staying in front of the the church
and then cut two years later 66 yes
still in such obvious pain it's tough
every victim and survivor I've spoken
with over the last year it never leaves
any of them how could it yeah I know I
saw I saw an interview with an expert
who said for most child abuse victims
the average age that they come forward
is in their early 50s
it is 253 and haunts them so long
and most statute of reform laws in most
states you have to come forward by your
early 20s so it's wonderful that so many
states are using the powerful new tool
yeah at the same time they have to
relive this all over it yeah very
powerful piece new qts thank you